oh wow
hey guys it's max angelica and vadim and
today we're doing another blind camera
comparison with the new nothing phone
one the iphone 13 and the pixel 6a now
max went out and he took a bunch of
photos with all three of these phones
and as far as we know we don't know
which ones were taken with which phone
and that's what we're gonna be doing in
this video so get out a piece of paper
and a pen or your phone write down your
results and let us know in the comments
which one won i will say this is gonna
be an interesting one we've had some
where there's a lot of similarities
there's gonna be some surprises uh so
let's go ahead and dig in here is the
first image sunset backlit and you guys
see the differences all right the middle
one looks really soft and weird and
super cool and blue like your white
tesla is like super blue i think the one
on the left looks like really good like
you can see all the details leaves yeah
the left one is by far the best the
darks over here are so completely
crushed while this brings everything up
you can see the detail and this is just
a blah image kind of dude
okay average
[Music]
the android phones are a lot cheaper
than the iphone here so that's going to
be interesting and all of them were
updated to the latest software the
iphone has had updates as well which
makes it better what do you guys think
we have a portrait shot here wow that
center one is so flat yeah it is very
flat like it doesn't have much contrast
uh the one on the left looks so sharp
she stands out so much i think i'm gonna
go with the left because of the
skin tones are warmer i think and i
think the one on the right looks kind of
distorted yeah definitely left left
iphone with the portraits and we have a
variety here okay this is a macro shot
and i was really surprised by the
differences
the one on the right
yeah look how sharp that is it's not
blown out um
it just looks really good the one on the
left is just weird and like dull i agree
pixel
another one for the pixel so far there's
nothing for nothing huh that's something
i was just trying to do
all right we have some kids inside with
mixed lighting
the one in the center just looks
flat just completely disregard that one
but the left and the right they both
look really really similar i'm gonna go
with the one on the right because the
colors pop more yeah i like the one on
the left because the uh the warmth and
stuff but i think i am seeing more
detail on the right like especially the
gray shirt a lot of texture another one
for the iphone
and we have our selfie it is backlit
with the sun going down tougher scenario
immediately i like the one in the center
that whole like back glow
from the sun is so pretty yeah i was
gonna go with the left until i saw that
the faces are really flat where you have
this highlight roll off that's really
natural
in the center the one on the right is
just too cool so yeah
iphone
another one for the iphone okay i
thought you guys might have picked a
nothing phone by now
uh when i was looking at him so
this is a portrait shot i always like to
do a really tough one where it's an
object not a person you have layers it's
really tough to get right wow what do
you think this one completely messed it
up at least that portion of it yeah
honestly i think i like the one
on the right because i'm seeing more
detail in like this plant i completely
agree in my opinion the center one the
blur up here just stands out so much
from at the bottom well this one looks
really natural looks real yeah
another one for the iphone oh man
um let's see what keeps happening
we have a portrait shot here i'm gonna
go with the one on the left the center
one it looks like it didn't work
portrait mode at all this one it's it's
really really intense but this looks
really natural and it keeps all the
detail on her face the hair everything
looks real yes i agree the one on the
right is kind of like overkill in terms
of the blur just everything just like
blurred out
and i really love the one on the left
because like this glow
from the reflection or whatever just
looks so natural
well the iphone costs a lot more money
so uh we'll keep that in mind
we have a sunrise here uh direct
lighting from the sunrise on the lenses
the first thing i noticed
yeah you saw that reflecting so right
away i noticed that all the details on
the right are crushed like all the trees
just gone so it's definitely not that
one but uh you look in the middle look
at all of this uh what is it flaring
so that definitely stands out so i think
the best kind of
overall balance is the left there's so
much detail yeah like you said in the
trees where that one's so crushed
good job nothing um i was surprised yeah
no reflections there the iphone actually
did have some not as bad
but the weird thing is the pixel
they used to be amazing on have not
having reflections but with this new
design
the reflections are starting to come
back so here we have a portrait shot of
venn shout out to him it's his birthday
today it's happy birthday
all right the one on the right is just
terrible like look at all the blur it is
so fake is it more blur better it's so
fortunate no not not in this instance
man i think the one in the center just
looks a little bit too dull especially
on the bike whereas on the left like
look at all that contrast
i think the one on the left looks really
good you guys are agreeing a lot in this
video sometimes you guys are going
against each other
i phone with the fortress and for the
nothing look at the color too
yeah that's the pink bike
ven does not have a pink bike sorry ben
all right we got an indoor shot with
some lighting
uh this is a very very tough shot you
guys see that they did it all really
differently i'm picking the one in the
center just because emily like the one
on the left she her skin looks blown out
like there's not much detail but this
one seems to be like pretty middle
ground and everything like the colors
look really natural behind her so the
one on the left is very flat and all the
details are just extremely soft the one
on the right i don't know what happened
it just butchered it looks terrible the
one in the center kills it in every
regard you got details you got the
highlights popping out yeah it looks
great
another iphone one all right so here we
have wow
super tough shot to get right not only
with the portrait but with the white
balance you've got the sun uh behind
there so there's a lot of variables and
these look a lot different i actually
took multiple shots to make sure and the
phones were consistent this is what they
chose to do so right away the one on the
right just butchered it it's just too
dark you wouldn't want this on your
phone the one in the center looks a
little bit too flat and i really like
the one on the left because it looks the
most natural with the sunset and you got
like the flaring that actually adds to
it and looks nice
yeah it looks really good left yeah i
was debating between the left and the
center but the the center one is very
flat so left
nothing wow
it's a great portrait all right here we
have a shot of this boat plane
hey flow
so what do you guys think left
left yeah the one in the center is like
a mess it's just yeah what is that white
balance is off it's super soft yeah but
you're gonna wanna read it has the most
clear text yeah so none of these have
dedicated telephoto lenses
uh this is a shot where you just zoom in
as much as you can and it has to use
this algorithm to take a nice shot
obviously you guys see massive
differences
the pixels beating out the iphone
less noise less artifacts more detail in
every way the nothing phone i mean they
got some work to do so here we have
another portrait shot right so i don't
like how dark the one in the center
looks i don't like how flat the one on
the right looks it looks like it's an
ultra wide portrait for some reason and
i think the one on the left just uh does
the best yeah and the center one as you
can see it messed up
the
portrait oh i didn't know
but the left one also like you can
actually see the sky which makes it it
looks really nice it makes a big
difference you're looking at you're
doing a good job you're taking a look at
the whole image
so both of you for left yep
iphone interesting video we said this
almost looked like an ultraviolet and
some distortion
and i guess it is a little bit wider
because i'm standing in the same spot
you guys probably noticed the pixel here
it's way more zoomed in they're still
doing the annoying thing where they're
cropping in on the sensor if you go into
portrait mode and they don't let you
change it where's other phones that give
you the option so in this case i
couldn't step back any further to adjust
for that i was just forced to take a
shot that you know that's like this
all right we have a beautiful
sunset
in coeur d'alene well middle yeah i love
that roll off it's like that's what you
see in real life you see it turn from
blue to like orange oh man why would you
want the house where everything is just
the same it's like weird and look at
this i know you guys already voted yeah
over here you have some different kind
of noise wow this one's for this
and the ish thing is on the phones it
maybe doesn't seem like as big of a
difference because everything's squished
down but then here it's massive it's
huge that is the
iphone and that's a tough hdr situation
all right we have an ultra wide shot
here ready after dark at the playground
wow well the left one all the darks are
just so crushed which is disappointing
because it's the only one with the sky
but between the middle and the right i
think i'm gonna go with the middle
i totally agree yeah you can see the
most detail everywhere uh the wood and
in the ground too it's a lot more detail
looks good
pixel pixel and look at that iphone
results oh what is that
that looks pretty terrible all right so
this is i believe it's a porsche but
it's further away wow the one on the
right looks really nice the one on the
left what are with the colors on their
faces
it's like over i'm sorry lina that i use
this photo over hdr or something
artifacts and weird colors
and the center one's really soft too the
details that go on the right ones like
yeah kills it everywhere
another iphone so this was actually
quite dark here
so they had to do hdr the portrait all
of that stuff and then shot of me for
the first time
is that a white shirt or a blue shirt
uh neither actually
i can't tell you guys what about i have
not been giving you guys any hints or
anything center one looks really
different wow yeah this is a mask wow
the center you actually have detail
everywhere these are all blotchy and
like terrible inside this left one it
looks like you were copying and pasted
onto that yeah there's a liner on my
head i don't know if it's the layering
that is impressive whatever took the
middle that is insane that actually
looks like a dslr
really good and this looks
okay well i think you guys voted right
that's a potato can right
okay so let's see
i wonder why that pixel was potatoes
doing that
that bad
very bad oh okay i think i know cause it
it crops in and it forces you to crap so
then you have to go further back but if
it forces your crop you have a much
smaller sensor effectively especially in
low light looks terrible now
this shot right here well this is
something i wanted to test because i
noticed something it's lower light on a
swing it's tough i took the shots at the
same exact time
um yeah you guys can vote man the left
one did amazing
yeah her face is like almost in focus
everything in the background you can see
the detail
yeah that's true the background looks
great and the main thing you want is the
face to be as sharp as possible so it's
the left that kills it and the colors
are natural compared to those yeah
another iphone shot and another
and another one one thing i noticed is
just that the iphone takes a picture
almost instantly yeah even when it's
lower light so quick whereas the nothing
there's so much shutter lag even a
normal lighting a lot worse than the
pixel and we have
this mess
is it a night photo night mode is it
nighttime is it daytime is it on mars or
i don't know where is blue the moon
well i would immediately say the left i
see way more detail in the sand and
everywhere the left one
yeah you like the color well in my
opinion
they look like night shots and if it's a
night shot with the lake or ocean
wouldn't you want it i guess i guess
that was that
i remember what it looked like i like
the center because if i look really
close you could see a lot of fine
details and like the people and like the
lights are really like cut out good
choice this is mushy right here but see
i don't see detail in the sand over here
well i see a lot on this one it's our
first disagree yep oh this first one ah
i think so wow you guys made it far
center center and left yep so nobody
votes for the right i actually don't
know which one is which on this it's an
iphone okay i think i'll take it oh
you've got nothing
nobody wanted for the pixel i wonder why
i'm so mushy here huh that's pretty bad
all right so oh wow
this is a what a circus uh i don't know
that's crazy so first off this isn't
we're getting into the night mode stuff
where they're taking pictures for you
know you have to hold it steady for a
long time
this has this beautiful warm light but
then we have you know the moon shining
down the purple lights
you know there's there's a kind of trees
in coeur d'alene right oh man the left
one looks gorgeous to me if you look
like everywhere around here looks
natural these obviously have the glare
there's so much detail yep i agree you
got the most detail in all the leaves
and you got like this really natural
glow like it looks realistic or these
just look like it just couldn't handle
the hdr yeah it's interesting how soft
because i don't want to yeah it's like
it's pulled down so soft everywhere here
and then this is like over sharpened
like
i don't know kind of artifact-y or
whatever
iphone we got another iphone shot that
looks so good um and the for usability
when you look at comparisons like this
all you see is the photos the actual
usability and yes we do like apple
products but we've had times where
samsung has won multiple times
uh we've said it's better than iphone uh
but the iphone this was a one second
exposure oh wow
here i don't know it doesn't tell you
the time it gives you a little new
circle in the middle it was either two
to three seconds and this was either
like four to five
a lot longer so the iphone's just like
one second you're done
and we have a selfie with that similar
light in the background so tough
situation here man immediately left look
at that yeah the detail it's the only
one that actually got like the details
of the light
still there while you could see like you
know facial hair it's the only one with
detail on the face yeah i mean look at
that you're like a blue
and here is a lot of noise in this shot
everywhere noise
uh so the left this sensor must be a lot
better
nothing nothing
okay i honestly didn't remember like
which ones these all were that's so
impressive i for i thought this could be
the nothing here obviously it so far
hasn't been doing that well but that
looks that selfie shot looks amazing
and we have this scene right here a lot
of mixed lights sun is down okay so the
left one i'm seeing a lot of softness so
you're not getting much detail
the one of the center looks really good
but if i look really close i am seeing
more detail on the one on the right and
i feel like it's a little bit more
natural and darker because it was dark
right
it was very dark a lot darker than this
oh and the roses or the whatever flowers
oh yeah notice that yeah those are
completely off man i was gonna pick the
center because i saw more detail while
this one a lot of stuff was crushed
but i i think you convinced me is that
allowed
i can ask you
if he can convince you i can't convince
you it looks good
i kind of feel bad there's two when he
like the nothing did great though it did
actually yeah did a lot better than the
pixel
oh
my kids finally convinced me to take
them
the last few times we were there we're
like nope we're not getting that or
we're not gonna go all right so i was
gonna go with the one in the center
because of all the detail on the ice
cream however everything is really so
flat
so i think overall i prefer the one on
the right yep the most the one on the
left is
so
so dark everywhere and this one is too
flat and this is a pretty good middle
ground
yep
i think so nice i think i like the skin
like this actually warmer and it's not
like it's
you know super bright there or anything
what happened here
um yeah wow which one do you like
completely different
wow i mean how how does a phone even do
this you know
it's like
so crushed yeah it doesn't make sense i
had to hold back that's crazy that's
crazy i mean this one is way too soft
it's like a blurry mess i don't know
yeah the one on the right for me it has
to be this one is so close to being
really really good but this whole
blurriness at the top is just really
off-putting it i would have picked it
otherwise even with her hand i know
you're choosing this now i'm just
wearing that [ __ ] so i know you're
choosing this one i just noticed that
what happened i don't know
i mean yeah it's doing a lot of weird
stuff so i will say it was this dark
okay yeah or darker i mean this is crazy
bright because it was darker than this
and then obviously you have this shot
right here
the nothing uh so this is all in a
portrait mode um i think maybe if it's
in portrait mode it can't do um the
night mode together you know iphones
used to not be able to do that it's only
the recent ones that could combine you
know for a result like this
and we have an ultra wide shot here whoa
there's so much graininess and artifacts
whatever everywhere this one looks bad
too
they all look pretty terrible they all
look bad
oh man which looks the least bad oh
that's tough which one would you want in
your phone i guess i would say the
center
just despite that just because
everything else looks pretty natural
i'll probably go with the right actually
i feel like i see more detail in the
building and in the flowers and stuff
and less of this weird blotchiness it
does have noise but this has this
weirdness i don't know to me everything
is just like way too blown out while
this looks more normal
to me they all suck they also happens oh
nothing all right
didn't get chosen yeah that was bad uh i
think in general uh like the last shots
we saw the ultrawide as far as the
quality detail is definitely lacking
even though it costs so much more money
whoa wow
elon's getting serious elon really
wanted a photo he was like no dad you
got to take a picture of me nice uh so
yeah this is extremely dark outside man
the left one is the only one where you
can see his face or mostly true so i'm
gonna go with the left i like the right
because i feel like there's more detail
in the right even though like one side
of his face is dark that's okay
you see like a nice clean profile the
side you know interesting
iphone and pixel nothing did not get
anything
we got this shot right here
uh this is all handheld
huh
i'm stumped
we need uh we need an s22 ultra to take
care of this
i don't know man it's just so
dark but which one's the worst and which
ones feel like that one is the worst
that one's the worst really
i'm thinking
everything just it's trying to make
daytime out of night time okay at least
you can see the details this one is
completely gone you want this and your
phone over that
yeah dude this is like it's dark here
and it's like blown out here there's no
color oh man i think the center is a
good middle ground i disagree i'm going
i feel like the center is a good middle
ground
pixel pixel and iphone and then we have
this dark shot well the left is a mess
it's got artifacts everywhere it's soft
it failed i think i like the one in the
center because it brings up the boat the
most yeah and the colors are true to
life too
iphone and we got
this
this shot right here was actually on a
little tripod wow um so yeah it's got to
be in the middle i don't like this at
all that one's too dark this one's
brought up too much
that just takes everything it looks
beautiful like my eyes didn't see any of
this
it must have been hit switch
so the pixel can actually do i think it
was a two and a half minute exposure oh
wow the iphone it'll do 30 seconds and
it's on a tripod yeah the nothing
does nothing
it does uh it doesn't go into like a
longer version i went through all the
settings so it looks artifacty dark and
i believe this is our last shot well
yeah the center
yeah it's the center this is handheld
yeah that's impressive i mean compared
to the other yes that was extremely
impressive
and it's the idea
the pixels
all this stuff artifacts
this is this in the dark that's crazy
i think this is where it just gets so
extreme
that the sensor starts making way more
of a difference because google has
compensated for years with old outdated
sensors but better software but at a
certain point you can't do that so there
you guys go
you guys voted um you guys go ahead and
pause the video tally up your votes we
want to hear your guys opinions down in
the comment section below vadim's
telling his up
i will just say
i
as a phone in the screen
it's nice it definitely is nice but
let's see what the results are
all right who wants to go first
you i'll do it all right so i got 19 for
the iphone
i got seven for the pixel and four for
the nothing phone
i got almost the same thing i got 18 for
iphone 8 for pixel and then four for
nothing so the nothing phone for nothing
got 4 out of 30.
uh it's a little bit disappointing of
course this is their first phone and so
much of the camera is not the sensor uh
it is the software sony makes most of
the sensors but sony software still
falls behind samsung and other ones
phones that use their
hardware so there you guys go let us
know your opinions were you surprised by
anything how do you think that nothing
did you think it would do better uh we
want to hear that down below hit that
subscribe button above if you guys want
to see more videos like this one if you
enjoyed it if it brought you value check
out one of those great videos right over
there that's been max angelica and vadim
and we will see you in the next video
[Music]